see on a day all the way from the
adulterated internet I was a guard at
the biggest pair of balls I've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life anal yoga prep
for you know what was what's that
you know don't spit on the Cocteau gag
on the [ __ ] back in the office is it is
it cuz obviously you feelin you like
some pig bones up my ass how many guys
you wrecked me about sexist I lost like
12 hours of the day this video will not
be monetized on YouTube I've already
accepted that so weird to be in a room
with like except for men cameras or
clothes on this guys I'm the one quite
the way that I talk way too yeah yeah
and they're my friends I want him off a
little cornutus like this like five
minutes it's a lot of hard work so
that's kind of what you're gonna be in
for today we're gonna just put quick
parental advisory on this might be
smuggled things
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Johnny Aneesa from propane
fitness and C on a day all the way from
the adulterated internet welcome to show
thanks for having me
- pleasure to have you on we have wanted
to discuss what life is like in a porn
industry for about what 31 years and we
got hold of you we finally finally got
you set you down on a couch different
couch you used to know casting couch ooh
oh this could be the most famous coach
that you've ever been certainly not
though I changed it was quite quite a
popular number yeah this also looks like
the public is it cozy
I'm just gonna warn you now this is not
waterproof so can we
and all stain-proof buddies bunk stands
already on it probably yeah
so that's kind of what you're gonna be
in for today we're gonna just put quick
parental advisory on this might be some
might be some other things but yet we
wanted to just ask you some questions
John you've crowd-sourced some from
friends so the first question first
question I want to ask how did you get
into porn Oh boring question how the
[ __ ] you get into porn everyone else
does the beginning yeah right beginning
no the problem was I was very very horny
which want to be a slag sauce thing kid
right I can't do not that must be where
I can like make use of this wanted to
[ __ ] everyone but I did a bit of like
web comment stuff before and then
whatever like the guy else has seen at
times I'd never [ __ ] about porn and I
was like how old are you 21
and so when I thought you know what I
thought I didn't actually see what porn
except for this lesbian porn and this
stuff on these tiny girls or I did
really know too much about the industry
and I thought you know I can do a little
bit of research on there and then I
ma'am I did stolen I thought yeah I'm
gonna get into it surely can't be that
out it's not as easy as you think
would you need to be licensed and
like is there training course' NVQ level
to do few teaching lessons okay cool so
if there we go straight off the bat
anyone who wants to get into porn
can you do it online course you can yeah
Google teach and you should have been
the students that can be the second I
can be the secretly so you had a skill
under passion yes I want to monetize
this yes well I know we didn't know
about a skill well yeah yeah when I was
young I want sin iam here just because
it's gonna cause a problem but I even my
need to go on the BBC teen and like you
look I would give blow jobs and stuff
hours off being very fascinated with
Sammy see teen yeah you know when you
could like Google like doesn't seems
like a baby seat yeah so that you have
that so I've always been very
interesting from being very like young
be pregnant fascinated or stuff like
that so remember it's like dope Lord the
[ __ ] it's dangerous it must call [ __ ]
dumb the lower what in case some egg
goes down the road I don't know what I
know the answer is you can yeah yeah I
imagine it's part I so do you remember
when you use the house
you know at home when you'd have a
SodaStream and you'd like pump the
SodaStream I mean it would be all
carbonate I mean it shouldn't be air in
there definitely so but I'm thinking
like how is he out gonna get out these
male equivalent of a queef to get out I
mean it would predispose you to
infection because you've been just open
up a bubble of in you glad is that more
basic do your not do that no okay so I'm
glad that we've got some safety in it's
not just it's not just all pleasure
ladies and gentlemen its act this is
real [ __ ] cutting-edge I'd like to
hear from if anyone's ever had that
happen I'd like to hear from them
because I can't imagine that it's
possible they're probably walking around
a diet I don't want to be the one that
has to deal with like infection
[Laughter]
I'll call you from the RV I'd let you
know so who do you contact when you're
like I want to get into porn so I'm
gonna ring because this yeah what do you
stop so and I just Google copy a porn
star doesn't give you a lot anyway I
found this YouTube interview of a porn
star and it was on him a company called
ATM ala their subscription and I just
messaged them because they were like in
the edge and I was like I want to do
probably represent me and they were like
okay let's organize a Skype Skype chat
and then I'm sent a statistics over so
for graphs and stuff and we'll go from
there
quite a formal process yeah it's a great
fun process and then they send you
around on the companies like show pony
see ya what do you mean that publisher
was it publishes
well they're like your age and then they
sent you to like for instance an evil
angel browser that your playground and
then be like so they could see you in
the flesh and see if they want to book
you for their shoe okay okay so you have
your selection process is it like yeah I
see it's not like you have to then do
free work until you get like I said not
like acting where you have to do kind of
free gigs extra is not gonna thing not
definitely free gigs right it's
interesting yeah is interested so no pro
bono work that's not okay so you've done
that and then tell me about your first
time first time on a porn set right
between which was my first time because
you did quite a lot at first and went
over and just did like a lot of stuff
went over yet to the existence why I'm
just because I could find more
information on that and anyway then I'm
it was even for a company called porno
Dan which is a live webcam sure oh it
was for hustler a carbon-neutral confers
might be portal Don and I will forgot at
the biggest pair of balls I've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life they took like
chicken Phillips
it's like two oranges medium-sized I'm
like Thomas a so it's quite a lot big
guys they enhanced or I'm not chewing
around asking so obviously I was
thinking what the [ __ ] so I absolutely
massive and they were trying to oranges
to oranges no bigger I'm talking I'm
talking like not [ __ ] like no like
rugby [ __ ]
yeah Wow anyway so that was quite
intimidated okay I'm only 22 and I think
it's [ __ ] out of this guy's massive
balls and quite a big [ __ ] as well but
then that was okay actually still got
that over and Domo as well to be fast
and then when I would puzzler there was
two directors it was like good cop bad
cop oh my god and that was dawning cuz
it was such long days he's very stuffing
like lots of people there camera lights
the guy kept one cut off the coconut oil
like because I've seen being a porn
locked I see ice was cooked chicken self
office remember kicking himself a
coconut oil consomme me thinking what
the [ __ ] is going on here down south
like no can you done yeah don't lead me
to a sexy dancer Hayes
still hits this day if anyone's like can
you do a sexy dance coconut oil this guy
kept putting off with the kicker's open
a coconut oil and Japanese [ __ ] to steer
hard I was remembering on what the [ __ ]
this is actually mental I think to be
thrown into that is your first first
experience as someone who like the I'm
guessing you flew over to the States on
your own yeah no family what I want no
one with you this wasn't like a DP scene
wasn't like a five on one no saw I like
I staged everything kinda boy girl
you're after did anal yes I did they
paid the after that they paid yes I
think like oh so this kinda this is yes
six now so there's like what a lot of
things to do so there's a hierarchy yes
there is
so when you start what's the bottom road
realistic mission solo so oh wow okay
yes that's like that's kind of a little
bit like the pilot episode right that's
before you can start yeah so you're a
member kit as much as you can talk you
so you do
three months or six months all of you
can't then years like right I'll do bill
bill to prolong your pawn life if you go
into an indigent everyone wants to shoot
you most hard courts and see if not much
what you do a stall off you mean shunt
in the house thank you once you've
raised that barrier yeah that's your
only ever gonna be out there yes
sometimes some girls will still it
depends on your fan base out populating
a bar but say your brand new you already
have that and you're doing a hard cost
often aqua do you wanna generally don't
to go back you know I mean understood so
there's like it there's a fixed path
yeah like I do boy girl now so I'm gonna
get booked for point my horse up my girl
but I'm gonna get boy girl boy girl and
all because they're like my highest
level to do or DP right mmm leave work
your way up to that yeah okay so
actually the boy doesn't a beginner
school [ __ ] great so we've got we've got
the fact is Chris you've started it
you've started in the industry been over
to America yeah then what happens that
would you do you go that right of I've
outgrown this agent it's time to me I
think us bigger penises like what do you
know I've got to the agent but then I
want it
once you have been established in the US
I could then have contacts in the UK
it's actually I don't know where if no
like how can I get into the UK industry
and then when I got back I started to
you babe station oh yeah which from it
does not for me it's too soft and too
long it's long days right long night
it's like ten or six and I keep it just
as the over six a.m. yes yes yeah
obviously I if I'm just on the Faunus or
I get to stock the atomic stare and
round and I kept my words mixed up
stopping like oh yes you can suck on my
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
so you just don't live TV yeah you've
seen that Bay of channels come on no
what was it weather like this I don't
have a TV so do you think that's a joke
sir
so is there a delay between like if you
make an error like that or if you you
can't hear what they said unless you're
at em like a spike or or something so
you have people listening to you don't
talk which gets you more money because
they appear like
Devoy attorney you just get this like CD
porn or music and that the girl like
doing like shake and the for not yet to
call and like shaken at it shaking
around will be fun him speaking no you
can't speak what she said oh this you
know one Makayla and Roxie two girls
from Leeds no I don't bring that they
David smashed it on babe state they're
both like well well into their 30s now
and still absolutely nailing it yeah if
you want to do babe session you
shouldn't still porn before really
because then you know you used to hide a
more hard core standard yes reason one
babe station first more glamour
glamorous any movie pollen okay and then
solo then by God go girl boy girl girl
oh it's a lovely especially fantastic
birthday [ __ ] because you still get an
insight to the the sex industry but
you're not gonna just do some of them so
do people who are in the more hardcore
thing look down on people who are invade
station because they are they're just
amateurs no they're just sort of a
different level they might be like some
girls that do poor might prefer
performing like visually or with props
of sorts rather than do do talk about be
very very good at do talk to do the
forms I think is like doing it's a
pretty different skill really yeah well
it's in doing anything monologue as
always respect for these women some of
the raps vocabulary we said all the time
right like if we've got the option of
recording a podcast for an hour or doing
a 10-minute like monologue to camera
give it up give me the [ __ ] podcast
yeah it's just back and forth right yeah
so you've done you've got back to UK
done all that sort of stuff let's get
into some nitty-gritty yeah the day that
I knew that I wanted to do a podcast
with you is when I messaged you a text
did you just catching up and saying how
was your day being what you've been up
to and you know I'm on the train at the
moment how about you and I was like oh
well like I've done this with my day and
I bit tired and had work last night and
this that and the other how come why
you're on a train you're all well I
actually feel a bit uncomfortable that
was it you feel a bit uncomfortable in a
bit of pain at the moment on a train
that's wrong well I've just been in
Amsterdam up to 30 days of back-to-back
DP so what you're doing tonight it was
like just the most oh yes I went to the
shop and the milk was out of day
actually and then this and I did 30 days
of back-to-back DP what your two of the
weekend house I I just need a window
into this world so fascinating that like
does it immediately like does it
immediately just to come it's just work
like okay
does it feel like the same as doing an
office job by the end of like having
done it for a few years are you just
like here we go again
right well is there still look is
everyone still think of work you think
of an office job yeah people think of
sex is like novels you kind of like when
you first start you're very enthusiastic
you little puffiness like yeah sake [ __ ]
when the camera's not on so fluffy I
won't you mean it's so long it's like
okay yep indica because you also want to
reserve your energy for the scene
because you expected to do more hardcore
scenes and I'll always give someone a
helping hand if there's just probably
the one or two years I'll always be like
enthusiastic and warm and welcoming to
the guy but the end to death guys there
to get to come with your job and saw you
you can't be expected to suck him off
for an hour before the scenes to get her
to I mean so listening to the riley reid
episode on logan paul which was the
apart from my very long history of
watching porn is my research out of this
show and listening to that I was really
surprised like she's incredibly
passionate about a job she sees it as a
genuine creative art yeah and she talks
a lot about energy and about like
of making sure that this seems beautiful
and all this one's got good chemistry
like I don't generally give someone and
a couple of goals to see what the
Energy's like because you could just
have like a bad worn off say but if
you've got a bad scene that's out there
so you want to really want to work with
people that like on your level too you
know when you come in you're both
professional you're both ready the guy
can keep his word the girl looks nice
and you just have a good strong scene
together in Europe - the same levels
mm-hmm so talk me flesh it makes it's a
lot content creation of the with it so
she wanted to be like really really good
so talk me through it's a day that
you've got work
you gotta graft talk me through morning
routine and then what do you do you get
to the set you know like a bit do you do
your own makeup is the hair and makeup
people there right depends what company
you work at for fits em accommodate
browsers easily and children took
playground though the big brother yeah
the base wants the ones a lot more neat
then take you're going an 8 a 9 o'clock
call time you'll get your makeup tour
and look at your hair done
then you do gram stills then if it's in
or you'll go prep for you know what was
what's that you know know what for anal
depository Duchenne and some girls like
to stick a pop rock up there after
stretch your I'll just wash them then
that's it it's ready to go okay so
you're pretty so quick yeah that's good
I mean that's gotta be an advantage very
easy which is a good thing you know
that's that's that's the opponent of you
being able to Cole bar deadlift 200
kilos without warming up just knowing up
like yeah yeah walk into the gym he go
how much do you have to look after your
own financial interests ease it said
like the certain cases where people will
want you to work extra unpaid stuff do
you have to always like would expect you
to like to the if you're having to do
like extra hours or do stuff that there
isn't being directly pay for it directly
or is it okay by our webpage yet you
decide yourself how you Piercy you
either
like debris or scenery so actually at
one time have quite a big argument for
the gentleman because I went around
there I did them I did the C of n say it
smashed it for very good positions gift
filthy hardcore [ __ ] scene and you've
recorded it on snapchat send it out and
then equals some estimates when I
started okay ten minutes of us start the
scene and I'm like whoa well which is
not gonna think up and we're like either
you've been pirated or like you know
stuff gets uploaded where you can't then
profit every single one of my movies
should be pirated but I've not seen
unless it's my last offer my only funds
can I get back to the big hitters there
yeah like you went through a few
characteristics that make a good scene
yeah so like can we just can we just
learn about those please okay it depends
on you she wouldn't fall like some
people like Winnie beautiful stuff I did
something product at the week it was
like cinema a cinematic cinematic
everyone so going over I personally hit
that [ __ ] like it's long it's
unnecessary your back ass like that for
like 12 hours of the day and then after
that you doing so elsewh look at that 20
hour long days and it's all soft porn so
you have total of about six minutes of
sex
I think 120 hour day but I personally
hear that but some people love it do
they do things like do they have like a
certain audience in mind button yes so
like it's to each person or makes a good
thing so he's like don't spit on the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on the [ __ ] don't be
aggressive don't be too loud too loud
too poor and then so then I'm scared to
make noise and it's like no no no it's
very very day isn't it okay so you got
that and then what about as we start to
move up through like more hardcore so I
descend more hardcore stuff so then it
depends but obviously that's the stuff I
prefer a good energy
hardcore someone that could keep up the
same tempo as you sing hardcore what do
we have cause like anal deep throat lots
of space upset all the big hitters right
okay Payan
you can say whatever you want worried
about things being gonna get pissed off
I feel like we are 20 minutes into this
podcast to film better you can now start
illegal Piron filming to film with me
it's an equal to people some watching
the sex I'm hanging it can't be illegal
to piss on someone's doing sex it must
be illegal to film you pissing oh yeah I
don't know the police knocked down the
door that's one of those like non crimes
that's that's reported in logged isn't
it Johnny even I know that you're rich
in can you come in here summit what are
they about the legality of it it's
illegal in the UK to be a prostitute
correct yes yes Court okay but if if you
if someone if two people move in off the
street there's money changes hands they
have sex in a room that's illegal
mmm however if it's filmed it's now not
illegal is that they tell you that
because the bloomery like what it's not
about like the the economic value coming
from a transaction it's from the way how
that's then sold on so you create a
product in simplicity if you if it's
being filmed in it's porn
it's illegal I think if it's not free
you can exchange money s cotton is your
load appears first on what the time
whatever happens if the treat to content
levels so you can still say that's
what's going on it's illegal to get like
a streetwalker
so that's that's four hundred pounds yes
go out for dinner let's go to the cinema
blah blah blah okay the payment side of
it so you always get paid but there is
like infinite free porn I mean tonight
so how how is the what i hears it being
salty I mean it make maybe there's a
massive group of guys who think it's
actually a bit porn politics so like
they're like porn or X videos I actually
owned by the company that I do porn
so they actually sort of technically so
I'll steal their own content so that
creator that's why oh sure I'm just
yeah they pay everything that's why I
don't like every ten minutes and then
you'll see the art you'll click on it
and you'll go to the website it's not
make sense
that's what born is never like 40
minutes long on porn videos yeah so for
us it's like porno but it's em a comedy
called mind geek but now a lot people
making them on content that's why I pawn
offered the premium we have fully fans
we've got Chelsea sing at Miami so those
kind of aggregators like are they
advertising for you or do they do they
ruin your profits long term and it's
very different because yeah I figure
Circle there's more of an effect because
the oils weren't being paid for like tip
and guys at tens of thousands of pounds
for seed to the thousands of pounds for
seen but now it's it's like a long a
long haul effectively it's not affected
me since I've started but if I just mean
done do it 20 years I don't really see
the effect of it on to like not you
specifically but like an average porn
star what's like you don't make money
from one pod video you make it from like
doing quite a lot pawn fit yours and
then doing things for your for yourself
and your porn is like yourself from
water so would you rather get royalties
from like videos that you do yes I want
about 53 million views that's 53 million
nice thing so we got royalties people
like millionaires right okay um I'm not
sure if this is gonna be able to work
link maybe in the show notes below
depending on what iTunes allow me to
pitying yourself if not it might be a
bit limit leader I am identifying
already this video this video will not
be monetized on YouTube I've already
accepted that sorry Dean
so what we said Johnny you've got you
must have some some good questions
that's it I mean they're a bit of a
no-no are they porn ER they businessí
they're all they're all related
supportin yeah it's not like what do you
think about brakes
yes no safe level okay so the first
place
friends you know I basically asked
people if you could ask again saw
something so this one is most people
pick their career and what they do
because they want like a pay rise or a
promotion or like they do it for self
worth like if you're a doctor you might
want to help people so by that I help
people that's a great answer do you get
that from
so do you get like a sense of you're
progressing yeah you really do you know
what I could do a lot of custom videos
as well for people and this is just
video nice to help people get that one
but it's very fulfilling going back to
just because it kind of relates what
you've mentioned there and again
listening to the right eerie podcast
it's totally right because this advent
of social media self-promotion funding
of self content and the fact that you no
longer need a publisher yet to do your
stuff
has meant you guys may not know about
this but there's only funds at Miami dot
VIP who's owned at Chelsea Ferguson's
gonna be on modern wisdom in a couple of
weeks time and this is where so you're
what you're saying is your porn is
distributed to a wide audience yeah you
do that people then become funds of you
doesn't yeah that's the funnel fixed-up
sees a great want to do it's not the
best payer but it's the best it's the
most normal widely one yeah so they'd be
like I love this girl on thick taxi let
me follow it Twitter in the night or
while she's still feel just that you
guys all the way let me let me follow
the flow when you're doing this stuff do
you have because when we make videos or
podcasts like we're very much thinking
about the person on the other end who's
watching or listening and like how can
we talk to them the most oh yeah are you
thinking of the viewer yeah I always do
little and surveys on Twitter or
Instagram and only fans and what you
guys want to seek next this week I'm
gonna do small penis humiliation
I do a little bit of research equip
because I'm not naturally like into the
dominate inside and that's kind of a bit
fetishy so but someone's asked it me to
do on their on my content so I'm gonna
humiliate is small penis what's the
appeal of private small [ __ ] or maybe
you think wants me sound it's a
worthless piece of [ __ ] I don't know I
would have to ask him which way wants me
to go from so usually they will want me
to say look at this big massive [ __ ]
[ __ ] yours is nothing compared to this
that's what they're after
yeah is it weird dynamic so there's a
couple of girls that I've known that
have done like financial domination yeah
like I got wind up guys
guys will get their paychecks send their
entire paycheck so their account is
zeroed out or max out their overdraft
send it to a girl and this girl then
drip feeds than the money they need to
live and some of the guys did this with
a wife and no no no no just take all
their money and then drip feeds them I
need to eat I need to put petrol in the
car right there's three quid back and
that's what they get off Isis fact
develop they'll make them more like you
take that as an example right so is
there someone is that like a boss of
porn is there like the mr. porn or mrs.
porn I don't know that's quite a tough
question really there's like you have
your classics but then everyone always
suit me do you know but this porn style
it's always like a different person but
is there some more like ah like is there
like a master but it's the guy demands
that what was the company you mentioned
to my gig yes yes a guy buddies out here
just over I think it's a account he was
the guy that was on Joe Rogan and it is
some insights like eighty percent of
pawn traffic remembering that porn
traffic it's thirty percent to be in web
traffic yeah I thought different
percentages for that like some people
say like 95 this lots of people say like
Lots
yes
I got that stuff from Logan Paul
certainly right but certain said that so
like fetishes if you I don't know but I
feel let's say you go back like a
hundred years I don't imagine there are
people like being financially dominated
or like doing some of the stuff that's
in porno oh yeah everyone create the
fetishes order a few actually it's great
question you said I mean like that do
people have these fetishes because
they've seen a porn video anything [ __ ]
no I really want to be finally she
dominate it was someone talking about
this saying that the creation of new
categories almost generates demand for
new people looking for weirder yeah a
lot of men I've been apart for a long
time and women we will need to think of
more more hardcore and outrageous things
to cut us off because it's kind of hard
to free person out to get off the fork
just a man and a woman having sex you've
got to think sometimes with some deep
dark seedy stuff and figure might not be
deep but I could see if something like
they defend Tom I think that I don't
know some people are quite phenolic eyes
and then they have these mad little
random sections so going to the porn
stuff how is holding down relationship
while you doing absolutely horrific for
you over the guy just the general
relationship every single part involved
no I do you know it's it's very hard
because think about guys get attracted
to you well the this Libby make you
through porn sometimes I might be like
funds your porn boyfriend's I have not a
porn boyfriend I don't think mixing
business and pleasure and it's just
haven't had that connection with someone
where I wanted to go out with them
nothing but great guys today I asked
them yeah I don't think that when they
get
fond of you and or they start liking you
a lot more they I don't think they
actually like seeing you as a sex object
no more and then they struggle with it
and they they don't want their
girlfriend going out and getting [ __ ]
and spoked on by other men there's
always jealousy this yeah it's the
jealousy really like guys jealous like
if you were with someone who was a porn
I'm a porn actor porn star no because
it's a job it's so different like Al
Gore that I can't even remember the
names of mouth slept with a porn you
know you go there you speak to them you
have a nice conversation
you make a good sing together you have
respect for each other then they'll call
on you - me too - ever again
enough so I think that probably strikes
on one that probably strikes on one of
the really like difficult to understand
things that most people think about when
they think about yeah because for most
people the reason that you have sex is
because it's this emotional bond it's
this thing which is incredibly intimate
it's not transactional it's not like
filmed there's not hair and makeup you
haven't done a douche before like all of
this sort of stuff and I think it's
about to teach a couple of friends to
douche how do you do yes you can get
them like douche bulb on your choice so
go make the relationships thing bit
difficult all done relationship yeah
because of some jealousy what about sex
outside of porn for you oh yeah it's
great
so you haven't fun that you've done
regulated your sexual appetite through
pause Oh a little bit you do sort of
like get desensitized because you saw
used to having sex
yeah you sort of porn sex so you can't
desensitize you for a little bit in the
fact that you're kind of a bit like you
can't have emotional connective sex or
what I just a little bit for a little
bit but I was recently [ __ ] a guy
this year you get that back a little bit
that's cool yeah so what sort of sex do
you have up southport just as every porn
sex outside of polar vortex dual sex did
you have that before you did porn
probably not as intense but it was still
pretty full-on and wild I died like
foursomes of threesomes and anal and
stuff before porn
big only started like really enjoying
like in on stuff after don't wanna learn
how to relax and clean myself
and you know the [ __ ] gone in push your
ass out and it sucks the [ __ ] up little
tricks like that
girls I want to do we really need
breeding I really need to do an online
course should be like a chichi things
top tips yep
okay there we go girls through glimmer
they go on to do an envoy from want to
do anal or whatever it is is it that
camera there what's it what's he tips
make sure your ass is clean douche and
Walmart the book look just sit in for an
hour if you like um when the [ __ ] got
it'd be look well lubricate it and push
your ass out and it'll swallow cockapoos
yeah
relax it's reverse peristalsis so that's
one of the key differences surely that
you said like the you know there's a
camera there and you'll be performing to
something yeah well sometimes iconic
cameras like over the guy's face you
can't even see them appeal v.i.c but
then if you're with someone there's no
camera so it surely that changes yes
sometimes it can be but em you get a bit
shy sometimes it feels oddly intimate
yeah excuse me I don't film it a neck in
my personal life as well would you just
get one of your flatmates in so he can
come and stand on the far side
he's get him to gesture while we're
doing things so I feel like I'm back it
yeah exactly
is it is it because obviously you're
dealing with guys who do this for a
living at work and then you're dealing
with then you sleep with someone outside
of porn he's just some bloke you
occasion have sex people is there is
there a massive difference like you're
dealing with like a railgun about porn
sexified bad normal sex run good porn
sex of good normal sex it's just it's
not the porn stars aren't like in a
league of their own
no I don't offer it no no that's
surprising no I thought that'd be like
an early have had some some bad porn sex
as well no no much evidence there right
what is your name of your first pet and
so you know this like the people say if
you're on your own my porn name is yes
the name of your first pet and like the
first treatment you lived on you
that's a Jets Imperial that is amazing
that really is I don't think that no man
you know cuz my mind doesn't work
yours was quite gonna smudge or any
means what's yours
[Laughter]
yeah one more time boss it's okay boys
it was a rabbit but my dad thought it'd
be funny to call it the name of like a
19th century Arab poet really any one of
them I found out in the industry when
you're six years old you just like oh
yeah that's a sick name from a Robin
yeah I'm very sorry you didn't think
about the future pause no unfortunately
okay so how many I'm gonna say guys how
many guys he wrecked me about sex with a
lot thousand three thousand a thousand I
know that's a very good porn sex for six
years
slept with quite a few before then then
this Lee personal sex yeah [ __ ] arse
what's these add-ons a piece of strength
to five hundred to a thousand you're
exposing yourself to a massive amount of
risk how do you like it
tested every two to four weeks and do
you get tested before a new partner or
like do you have like tested every two
or four weeks anywhere in about six
years that's been a longest I've gone
well get tested would probably be two
months for the past six years okay who
tested the company that's you know
yesterday's get it done there's a
company in Dean Street and that used to
give us six hours general results we
need our results fast again you know
start off our window yeah and you have
to get tested for chlamydia gonorrhea
syphilis HIV have to see you happy what
are the diseases
okay everything goes and then didn't you
say that there's some sort of
certification and everyone is a part of
this same like yeah you have to make
your health certificate which is signed
I don't ask me like what is the
company's yeah okay so everyone's kind
of unionized into this also you won't
have to say that these marks have 70
people you've slept with it's because
you work with the same people over and
over again so of course we a lot less
than I think because I thinking hold on
I work with that guy a lot all for that
period of time so is it really that many
or is it more
hmm so that probably creates a
protective field around the industry
because if any yeah it's getting tested
all the time it's soon I think it's the
rise of like the rise of the porn
industry the spread of HIV I think
happened at the same time that's
bellevigne before like you got all these
people having sex high-volume sex I got
someone men got here try me this year
who was a horse I we have it that's mm a
three-month break where no one shoots
any part just to make sure it's not
spread within the industry everyone read
like ya know EV is thinking how do you
any money if you like enough that's why
you've got to have like a backlog of
content you're going solo yeah yeah that
is that is literally the same protocol
h1n1 hey Sean anyone remember when no
one crab sext each other the virus yet
not enough sex but that you totally
right so I want to talk about the
only funds in the admire me de IP stuff
as well now so is that kind of changed
the game for you guys a little bit yeah
so like there was a point where I think
like the companies and producers
directors whatever these people they had
a lot of control over the industry and
there was more and more girls coming in
and then maybe doing it from lower rates
because the European girls have worked
very cheap because the from you know but
now we got the opportunity to make a lot
more money because we can sell our own
stuff now so we always been able to buy
sites like many vids and or the platform
websites but now it's just for some
reason these two websites have blown up
I made so much easy for everyone so how
many funds have you got on your things
and I have about 400 on my only funds
and I'm not too sure on my mind mind me
it's a little less on that websites I
started only funds for this I would like
to transfer them all over it's quite
difficult to get them from one to the
other and how much is it to subscribe to
you and $15.99 for Olli funds and I'm
not sure Mike right now just changing
the other day I think offer sales so
sometimes though that's a monthly $59.99
yeah I supposed to transfer people over
you have to get them to re-subscribe
people yeah yes some people know so how
often do you get recognized by fans or
by like yeah sometimes we'll be a bit
shy and the more wanna send a little
message I'm sometimes go from to keep
chase yeah like an end right a guy just
like for real [ __ ] seriously yeah
does it does it intimidate you and when
people know no they usually just say I'm
excitable okay yeah I've Nvidia
encountered any like absolute lunatics
because something we find is that like
people who watch podcasts with videos of
us they'll come up to us because there's
a very one-way sense of familiarity like
they know us because they've seen our
content but we don't know who they are
they're overly familiar with us yeah
they're just like yeah I think that
leads to befriending strangers cuz poor
not to come up the people have become up
and sayin like so with us good example
someone will say do you remember on
episode 5 when he said when you when you
spoke about the Pomodoro Technique and
you said that you do four on one off but
I do five on one or two people have come
up to you and go remember that scene he
did it was with like this this this
person and you're thinking I did that
that half a decade ago I'm good I
suspect I remember like someone sent me
an Elvis Presley book cuz I probably I
said I liked it once in it I skip it I
don't even leave over soon it's my
little things like that Johnny what we
got next
you're two more questions yeah what is
the worst thing was the worst experience
you've had and what is the best
experience you've had
I'm quite lucky I've not had too many
bad experiences that when that guy I
tried to get me to do another scene off
the snapshot was originally called me a
psychopath that I don't you stole from
yeah yeah yeah it was trying to exploit
me to get more for his money but
obviously then you stood my ground and
I've had a couple of situations like
that I once had a glamour see you where
the guy was trying to sort of like be a
bit pasty and you know crack on with me
I was just glamour photographs but other
than that everything's being really good
I mean quite looking oh and the other
thing is shooting really really long
disliked 20 hours it's rings when he
knows yeah that's just not for me no
more that type of work yeah 20 Union
we've got one on the [ __ ] but they're
always kicking off on Twitter well I
mean that's exactly why I've long people
not see the Union of the Union because
the Union don't actually shoot porn
they're just these people who in opinion
that's everyone on the internet it's not
you know they don't actually do anything
they're just a
the Twitter again any keyboard that can
what $43 a vessel yeah you highlight
some of your highlights one that comes
to mind
god it's hard I did a great tak see
Rebecca more my controls are very good
seen severe there with him fake taxis
have always been fun actually have you
done the female one have you been a
driver for fake time no I haven't
actually
actually lots of four components I've
been really really good and a DP DP for
Digital Playground for Bulldogs peanuts
scores was a beauty he's good just
because it was it looks really wicked it
just like it felt good it looked good
the guys with goes we already go on I
think the best things and once I like
come out looking wicked you have a good
time you're laughing you know you're all
professional that the sex is good mmm
the the things like faint taxi in like
where it's like fake something yeah
obviously that's not real taxi taxi but
it's not it's not an action yeah yeah
but like all the casting couch stuff
yeah how is any of that like footage
from because presumably you have to have
an interview like that at some point or
there's gotta be some or is it like if
you are in a situation where someone
said yeah he's doing custom couch I'd
say wrong cuz they're like obviously
he'll run yeah dodging [ __ ]
right yeah sure okay I think there are
some realistic ones like that out there
but I've never come across I think
that's more understates or very
low-budget you never work for nothing so
you never peer somewhat some girls
appear people like why are you paying is
just be very important yeah like they're
casting or whatever I'm guessing
yeah it's people saying they want X but
expecting X times 10 right yeah I
understand what does your training look
like like a gym routine Chris was like
ready fYI fYI if you have a look like
Sienna you are in fantastic thank you in
the corner I know you are but like
you've done a lot of work I think of it
definitely since I've known your last
three four years yeah in terms of
transport heavy beam it's probably about
a size 10 but I would eat it the money
five four so I look quite curvy and I
didn't like that and I handles a lot of
walk with it so I'm now a dealer weights
like five times a week
wait five times a week well push four
legs or what no I like I do everything
separate so that chest method I don't
like it caught it confuses me I'm like
what's on this yeah no I mean super sets
so you do a body possibly with super
seconds five times a week three five
five
she's like I don't separate all the
minutes they'll be like if I'm doing
three it's because I'm working okay
right other managing five and so I have
you got a trainer
are you following it yeah I'm with a
trainer guide and a Bradley max it an
empty care okay and was that was that
your idea you're like I'm gonna stop oh
I'm not seeing him as much I'm seeing
him next but I'm doing more at the gym
because I'm wanting to effectively sort
of separate but I'll make sure I see and
for my legs because that's when I can
get a bit lazy for tagore behavior it's
not the standard in the industry of like
that with the the porn stars will lift
well lift weights or like the people
there's a small group of bills I'm
really into the fitness but then porn is
so wide there's a lot of girls that
aren't but a lot of men and off quite
big girls actually so there's that Anish
for everything but me personally I feel
better when I'm in [ __ ] so you like
yourself to look the way that you look
and you all then saw spawn that once you
looking that way yeah that's a while
surely that's gonna be the best way to
do it
no like study how you want to those not
like but also just tomorrow fitness as
well when your cowgirl and reverse
cowgirl like yeah I guess they're like
this like five minutes it's a lot of
hard work myself for 20 hours yeah like
bench dips to prep for that I've got a
very French tip something but actually I
was quite impressed with them in the day
there are new things any specific porn
exercises you do like grip strength
you know like those like weighted neck
things like I reckon are you wicked as
oh I reckon you would as well yeah I've
seen your videos so deep like yeah do
you do anything that is for work no I
don't do anything work and we're quite a
car or isn't it oriented so what would
you what's that one adductors yeah thank
you okay yeah yeah but you might have an
it was did it's gone we'll do an
assessment that right so is there anyone
that you don't tell like or like friends
that you just don't talk about the
subject with cuz like oh I'm not only
going to my civilian friends I'm being
like a hard shot by two men today that
bring the load all over my face and blah
blah blah I thought because he's sparing
them the like no just because there's
not really you don't almost got your
friend to say what happened in your job
do you know I mean I think yeah you know
sometimes it just it isn't relevant to
the conversation we're going to chatting
and it just doesn't come up with to say
at me or what's gonna work this is 30
days of back-to-back TPM on a training
prank
what is 30 days of back-to-back TP like
I might not be speaking for you might
just bring DP in or but it's hard work
and your ass'll at the end of it needs
some time off let's say yes until your
season what's up with that is it like
just you wake up in the morning my for
[ __ ] sake like I really I can't be
asked to do that today well did you ever
you ever have days like that or not yeah
but do you know what usually once you
understand like maybe get coffee or Red
Bull in your and chief Eden get your
makeup done you chatting away and then
you talking about the scenes gonna be
you kind of get in the
three because you'll want to do it
external accountability CrossFit model
you got reprimanded on Twitter recently
you're saying just before good cheers
again now and I am my asset I'll try
some plastic someone's under at the
Internet
can you please tell us about this iPods
my [ __ ] out since are allowed are so
loud yeah you are but it was in my head
and it wasn't my full a soul so I like
this little yellow song on and you could
see him the rim the rim the rim and the
other one happy but that's what the kick
be off some pop in the guy's number
yeah that a guy kept pestering me I
won't take things so I'll put his number
on the Interphone this is my number 17
notes so he reported me like that guys
missed a trick by not making a big deal
about to get you SIM card I think you
make video about it and talk about it
great viral wouldn't it great con sense
right again accidentally had it was just
people offered some is discrimination
some girls will have more visible I saw
some others because people have been
banned from Instagram for having a big
fan of instructive and snapchat walking
well because things like um someone had
a blood stain on that bed from from
their period and that was that they got
their I can't ban on Instagram because
it was like I have read things all that
they they look look into your DMS and
stuff as well if you're offering certain
services really kick you off for that so
it's not just because solicit through
yes I think that's what somewhere some
girls or guys have gone wrong I think
they're soliciting Indians
so I'll be told anyway tell about
Twitter just use eyes a wild was one
mental guy right on Twitter my friend
Ava she got those took down this guy was
like I had and reporting on you Pawn
Stars to Instagram you're all gonna be
taken town I'm all gonna get you all the
thing into that it's not aI don't know
what happened so he seemed so just sort
of bored
banana yeah I think something is just
there that wanted to report yeah he's
not doing any
the man on the planet a favor is he
buddy you got some mad guy that just
messages me saying slag bimbo and then
it like [ __ ] get on webcam now slag
boomer I'll show you my emails off him
got caffeine mark happen a lot I do get
haters just this one guy read has been
doing it for you 54 million views one
guy man 1 hey guys it's very usually
most people are quite sound to be fair
it is always a vocal that we we get one
guy that always emails us like he was
reciting to our thing just to be like
she sends us emails that just nothing
else great at Johnny more questions and
if you were to be suddenly or if you
were to paraphrase this if you were send
me in charge of the porn industry what
would you change or what do you do
different questions what would I change
I saw no you know it's it's a tough one
there's quite a few things that do need
a change of in it I'd probably just said
better is for the performers is there
isn't if the main one but that's sort of
being like resolved itself with these
sites like only fans and admire me
because that was the main issue is the
lore it's because of the piracy piracy
was quite a big issue for us and then
streaming yeah came in that's extreme
like pornhub.com is Spotify for artists
spawn of the porn stars isn't it like
they get paid such low previously you'd
have to have bought the album to listen
to the music
can anyone upload this model hope that
the do before we did used to get
anything from them right we didn't used
to get a penny but now we can make our
own and model profile and we can so
people can find our profiles and pay and
we can get money from it but before we
couldn't have that so say if they paid
you so and so money for a see that's all
you've got off them and it won't be a
part of it before the company who you
work for and then pornhub soul for
content so the way it was born of is
like a bit like am allowing wire or put
Locker
but now they like but now now they want
you outside because you're making your
own money yeah so you're in your hands
now
yes for the agency so it's changing for
the good that's there
I don't know whether you've seen but on
porn hook now they can metatag the
characters are the actors and actresses
within porn videos so it'll be like in
this particular video this person this
person this person this person and then
from that you follow through and it's
got a bio of like each right the
performer and then within that all of
the most recently uploaded videos and
then the most like an artist pages yeah
videos now so then I'm chatting my two
pages linked at the mid now and then I
look Lord on my homemade Potter 2.0 and
get paid for that now do you know is it
is that kind of similar like YouTube ad
revenue type thing like just I don't
know idea about that good okay how much
do you ever get exposed to like because
presumably you're in a world where like
there's a line and then [ __ ] gets really
illegal really quickly do you remember
me are we talking about in person I mean
I just mean like the sex industry on the
internet like when you're talking about
sex on the internet there's the legal
side of it and then there's the illegal
side of it where people are getting
arrested for having images and videos
that they shouldn't have
underage stuff okay oh of course yeah
I've never seen that there's you seem
really confused I don't know what you're
trying to say just how like how is is
there any reference to that like do
people acknowledge it or talk about it
oh that's nothing to do with like even
though that's called pornography that is
not pornography or something yeah we've
got legal contract role test field
everyone's most everyone's willing we'll
do videos up again and say and I'm
sanitaire I'm sober and I'm willing to
do show you know what if they're not at
the beginning of everything right so
yeah well for most of them so that sort
of stuff is of pornography Dutch people
exploited certain certain situations and
they call it at pornography they're like
in media like films and things like that
they portray some of the arse
it's not it's a clogs it's not does not
step going on there with underage girls
or whatever it's getting done it's
someone exploited that would film in it
on the sly isn't it you
we also mean like sex workers and stuff
like that or people that are down on
money and then they're just doing stuff
for like 20 quid and someone's another
phone now I just I suppose like I
imagine that there's a bit scantily must
be this thing of like we need to make
everything 100% legal all the time more
than every illegals in Prague a lot just
cuz that's what the addiction company
that's just by the law production goes
I'm sorry actually bill passed our
products gone gone downhill I guess they
don't want to shoot that much I guess
it's just because it's cheap slot
stunning girls there it just seems to
work out I don't know just how it is so
you have you got a YouTube channel or a
podcast like would you ever do non-porn
content and then like take people over
to it like so where YouTube like you're
not allowed to do anything that's you
know against their terms yeah but then
like build a following on there and then
move people over
yeah yeah it's definitely something I'd
look into but you're just gotta be so
careful and one of the so used to being
a poor it's kind of I don't like I said
to you a deal like what can I say what
cannot serve I kind of swear cursive
yeah it's quite hard to sort of like
would you get D monetize for saying
sexual stuff ons but this doesn't make
there is not a cut in Hell's chance that
this episode is going to be monetized
right interesting
I got do you monetize for doing a video
with the people that did a documentary
about Madeleine McCann really yes are
they okay um yeah
given the choice between doing a podcast
or doing YouTube and getting the
exposure off that and just getting
shagged for a day putting on pornhub
I'm gonna guess pornhub is gonna drive
you a little bit more traffic so until
there was a period where you a lot right
there's I got somewhat really [ __ ] a
lot of different ways to bring traffic
in because we know that's what happened
to one today it's just throwing cuz like
if you had a YouTube channel it's a
different audience and watchin it would
like like if you just did like a series
of q and a's with a porn star and I
imagine you have loads of people that
are interested in like what is your life
like what the same yeah well that's how
I got into porn is a YouTube channel was
it yeah see I wanna say I really really
think that these are the people to take
you online how to get into porn
to prep for anal how suck a dick yeah
well you know guys join forces like
video editing high production lighting
Ichi of experts like theirs what more
could you want great refreshment there's
more there's more stuff on Netflix I
feel like lately oh yes when porn and
yeah seen all them I feel like it's gone
from being to boot your better mind this
is what I mean they don't gotta get
someone mega successful to do when porn
ends other you know cuz Pullman still be
going they're not gonna get a Jameson at
65 still going away do you have a you're
probably just not gonna be interested
you're like I'm done well philosopher
I'd love to answer this one too
documentary I don't have to do so but
the people that are maybe a little bit
not gonna say Vista because I can t
remember the full thing but maybe them
upset the industry I'm gonna want the
voices heard out there age like is that
like if you're professional sports men
you can like play it today you know I've
just seen that mega old people right
what's the oldest person you had sex it
pretty alright we're talking like 50
grand paddles teases grandpas teams mom
and grandma good you know what I mean
that could be would have English does
all Hungarians yeah she had the hair up
Posse ever actually not to bother
developmental is good-looking I don't I
don't think they've got porn people I
think they were just horny old swimmers
right yeah how did they perform
yeah well one was a BG of saying I'm
almost I can just mean this grandma
[ __ ] looking
what was it good thing BJ BJ scene right
okay you got you got you
so talk to me about fluffers the
flippers exist
no no such thing yeah so the guys well
it's that month yeah love actually so
it's just like go crack on over the far
side guys take my hecklers and like why
you said lock them in check their dicks
[Music]
I'm not too sure I'm not looked into it
they don't have to be horny that's the
thing it just goes up sometimes they
have to inject it to go down we are
fixed bunkers
Galvani my [ __ ] in my ass under my
mouth gaviscon this is mint tea as well
isn't it yeah
pretty nice it is great for heartburn a
little bit that's my breakfast yeah but
yeah then you have a bit gaviscon
[Music]
because my guys were injecting now I
think definitely if you're if you're as
a guy cuz there's a girl it must be
easier to become aroused like the level
of arousal that you mean to be able to
bond but still to have someone inside
you you've got to feel comfortable
because it is quite invasive so you want
to be comfortable you're having a guy
inside of you and it's gonna be for a
duration you know you want to be feel
comfortable on in a good mood for it's
not probably simplest slip it's not a
bit of lieu but I'm crack on with it if
you ever had to say like today it's just
not happening
no I have walked off sets why have you
walked up and if I just felt the
company's or professional orful felt
they were pushing boundaries that I
didn't necessarily agree wearing a tie
bondage one time absolutely yes I listen
obviously am I expecting payment if I'm
walking off set and unless I felt like
they were at fault and then with my
tongue fits something like the bondage I
was like listen I just can't do I don't
like being tied up so I walked off that
one another one sir in pornos you need
one two three cameras to catch the ankle
they were trying to do everything a wall
camera I was understand that I'm cool to
the ship you got a technical rider you
know I got it some DJ's they turn up and
they say like I need to have to DJ em PA
system of this particular size I need
this many microphones
I need this looks like out put on the
lighting most companies a grid or the so
prepared under so fast on the saw just
like on the ball for everything the
light lobby set off and saw if they've
got the camera stood there they've got
one move in if your [ __ ] thing have
you ever been have you ever been hit off
the boom no never
it's Mike I hope you know it's quite a
bit
the size of our booth what are your
thoughts on like there's been a TED talk
recently and there's kind of this
movement of this that's very much saying
that porn has this like societal impact
on young man and like unrealistic
expectations of sex and body image and
I'll tell you today about that poorer
white broad is so like we're in Tenerife
and then each morning we'd have a coffee
and on the final morning there was a
knock on the door five orders of coffee
and the room service I was like oh he's
your coffee you see a bear the mind
wheeling like absolutely look we're
about to film like a three less more
[ __ ] see and I'm like oh great thanks
like can I have another one and he'd
come back up I was like do you want to
film or Sam blessing off basically and
the guy was like yeah and then he said
cracking so horny can i one can I might
yeah tweet it's not something under the
bed if you like this guy's I'm the one
quite the way that myself waiter yeah
and they're my friends I wanted him off
alone cornutus so it's not the guy and
the guy was happy being in the video so
you could just hear him in the
background I mean not about is a very
specific example the bellboy okay in the
same hotel yeah imagine if those two go
in the staff room me you'll never
[ __ ] guess what just happened to me
me you will never he was you had so
Riley Reid said that she shagged the guy
from Home Depot that came round to fix a
door like her door her door was broken
and she had sex with the guy from Home
Depot the camera on to fix it
has there ever been like situation or
the situation sagasta me before that it
gives a [ __ ] to but I knew off him so
wasn't quite as is if he was a stranger
but then yeah I notice I kill some more
home decor DIY another thing actually I
needed more plaster and funny ones air
available
we'll be in Netherlands Johnny you got
any more questions
the last one was just relate to what
you're saying so what was the first
thing you were asked to do that you
declined yeah what its bondage on I
don't like me beside all perfect it sir
do make you feel claustrophobic callous
whatsoever I don't want to be tired it
really have you ever been tied up Johnny
no no would you want to well no I don't
think so I don't look at that thing
you're right you twisted a lot wasn't
there like in case baby somewhat I mean
you trip back to though yeah UK just
doesn't it doesn't fill me with that's
like something I want to try it's like I
tell you guy when one came off of the
weekend yeah
did you untie him yeah yeah I'm sorry
okay yeah tell it to I'm just thinking
about whether or not we can get back it
to tell you up Johnny Rick's back we're
not talking about that if you're
listening have you you love the kit yeah
I've got a couple of ropes great so
we'll need to be strong ropes yeah they
will the still hundred kilo something
well I suppose I mean if your hands
behind your back
what do you get inside to something got
just tired look that's the thing there's
so many different ways in it the radius
just feels really
how are you d need to me like you know
final thing so that my last question I
Riley Reid got asked this and shared a
really interesting answer um women in
the porn industry there's a lot of
articles and and stories going around
that women upon industry aren't treated
very well that they're capitalized on
what's your vision or what's your
experience of being a female in that
industry I'm looking at only really had
positive experiences but I'm I feel
confident myself to demand a level of
respect within the industry and off
people but I've seen those girls out
there that maybe have been mistreated
bit I don't feel like the by proper porn
like the top porn companies I feel like
it's probably by low-budget men with a
camera trying to get something out of a
girl just a guy with a case yeah
yeah so if there was if there's some
aspiring actresses out there that want
to move in wild stuff just stick to the
big names stick to I would no no just
even do your own [ __ ]
just just son your own content you
should be able to follow it on Twitter
get your nudes out there you know I'll
get people talk and get your retweets go
only France [ __ ] it's been like
decentralized and if you want to shoot
for company shoot for a big one that's
gonna build your profile yes sometimes
people yeah it's okay so you got maybe
not even faketaxi let me just go
straight to browsers if you guys I was
gonna say so if you were to design your
own little prodigy porn actress or actor
yeah yeah yeah exactly well I mean first
off you want to be a reseller well on
the accounts you get a commission but
after that you get to do it's come to it
is his kind of pimping browsers yeah
browsers be top its president number one
it depend on the style it's a really
good company to shoot for is very very
popular exposure I want to get added on
upon actually UK is definitely safe taxi
I think okay but then and then browsers
because they pay accord they look after
you they'll get company to shoot for
they got good refreshments hospitality
yeah they do I've got a freshman
hospitality great and then here's number
three who would you put number three do
this fig out of Gainesville angel but
that's the Haskell yeah okay now um a
guy from the industry that some
listeners may know and a girl from the
industry that you'd like to work with
that you haven't or one that you have
that you would like to work that again
no I would like to do its mmm mmm the
American [ __ ] and [ __ ] because I've
had a lot of the the UK talent now so
that's thinking the US Johnny sins
therefore I think he looks like a career
performer and girls very she's amazing
good night kisses ins Adriana check it
yeah yeah she's yeah there's more girls
the song is stunning stunning girls in
that there isn't one I'm not guys as
well as please God and who else's
it's hard to think of the top of yet
don't even know what spitting off still
a big big deal was a peat moss I shot
for him but not for these days on
company with yeah shot fears website but
not fair talked about because you
sometimes number the Twitter name shot
the Instagram man's so whoever's being
slide yeah so you're kinda finger what's
the rocks on their that's killed so
what's what's next like obviously you've
got this decentralized way that you're
now owning your own money which you're
in complete control of I'm going to the
burn and X X phase which is like a sex
porn award ceremony for a certain like
brunch I guess product explicit all of
the words for it but and that's gonna be
a burden which would be quite good could
mingle with people me some of you people
I've got some content mantle for that
that's all yeah will you ever retire
from port a bit I mean I can just start
and to do mill stuff now on milfs is
such a great like category do get away
with milf stuff no yeah cuz I've got
faked it to sneeze tips Father's Day
card that's nice when the sole
subjecting they told me 30 when I was 23
so you're doing milf stuff because you
got big boobs
as soon as you are fictive sand poured
not that you could be a MILF but I can
still did Leon stuff as well from and a
great player so I can do the the younger
self and the milf stuff
nothing like after you did if you chose
to retire is there a concern about like
like what you would do afterwards or if
you know no I'm what would I'm gonna be
our players but I can then retire that I
won't need to worry about a job
afterwards if you got your only fans up
to that for figures like for a thousand
people plus yeah that's yes that's a
house of year that's a nice deposit
amazing yes so once you've done actually
I've got a fantastic accountant I got a
great mortgage on my account
Chris I know that you're listening Chris
I will be in touch to
expect an intro email you know exactly
what I mean
Sienna do not tell me yeah that you have
gone over the backbone threshold before
we finish any more questions guys this
has been fascinating pleasure so weird
to be in the room with like except for
men cameras or clothes on well there's a
penis that comes in through the door and
then just yeah it is Sienna thank you so
much for your time if people want to
follow you what social networks are you
on I'm back on everything so Twitter is
a day in Siena I do not harass her on
Twitter or your number um yes all right
you can't arrest me you can't sleep on
my team so there's something yours if
you fund do not I just have to follow
them I think okay and my Instagram is
another day in Siena because if they in
Siena got bad don't bother stuff shall
not on their no Marcus to avoid it I
didn't even do anything bad that's the
thing I just like slide to to flush or
something and then yeah I got all my
details from I only found my porn a
profile is on both of them links in the
show notes below Siena thank you so much
for your time you know thank you
[Music]
you